FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for coming today.
So today we have a
very special guest.
Just a little bit of
background on Ruth.
So Ruth Sherman works with
top CEOs, celebrities,
and small-business
entrepreneurs to help
them become charismatic
speakers, presenters,
and video and media darlings.
Ruth has worked with some of
the world's largest and most
prestigious companies,
top CEOs, movie stars,
international celebrities.
Four of her clients have
won Oscars, and one of them
has won the Pulitzer Prize.
Her many film project include
"Dallas Buyer's Club,"
"Insidious: Chapter
3," her first horror
film, and the recently-opened
"Suffragette" and "Trumbo."
She loves getting
paid to watch movies.
But you don't have to be
famous to work with Ruth,
and she's here today with
us, so that's awesome.
Her new book, "Speakrets"--
which is outside.
Everybody should grab a copy.
It's amazing.
I read it cover to cover-- "The
30 Best, Most Effective, Most
Overlooked Marketing and
Personal Branding Essentials"
is the name of her book, is
available on Amazon and just
outside this room.
She's also a
widely-quoted expert
on political communication
who knows that the better
communicator always wins.
Her first career was as one of
a handful of successful New York
jingle-singers,
whose voice was heard
around the world on commercials
such as Coca-Cola, Ford,
Michelob, and Clairol,
and as a backup singer
for major recording artists.
Ruth holds a Master's Degree
in Speech and Interpersonal
Communication from NYU.
Everybody please
welcome Ruth Sherman.
RUTH SHERMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
First things first.
In order for us to
have this discussion,
you've got to leave your
politics at the door.
Do I have your pledge
that you'll do that?
Yes?
Shake your head.
Just shake your head.
Yes. [LAUGHTER]
This is the hardest
thing to do, by the way.
It is very hard to not have
opinions about candidates,
because what I'm doing
today, of course,
is using them to talk about
speaking and communication,
because we're in the midst of
this presidential campaign.
So this is one presentation
that I roll out every four years
because I think it's so
fascinating to watch how
these candidates communicate
and influence our vote,
or, at least, try to.
So leave your
politics at the door.
The only way that I know that
I am doing it right, when I get
interviewed by
media, because they
call me to ask me
what do I think
about what the
candidates are doing,
and who is doing a good
job, and who might win,
which I don't predict quite yet.
They always ask me, and I
always have to be very careful.
We all have our biases,
and the only way
I know I'm doing it right
is when I get hate-mail
from both sides. [LAUGHTER] OK?
All right.
So there are a couple of reasons
that I do this presentation
every few years.
The first reason is that
I think it's important.
As an expert in
communication, and somebody
who's doing this for
a very long time,
I think it's my civic
duty to inform the voters,
and people who come
to my presentations,
about just how the candidates
use these communications
techniques to
influence our vote,
as I mentioned a moment ago.
The second reason is
because this is a master
class in public speaking.
I was talking to a few of you
here before we got started.
And it's important to
pay attention to this,
because we can learn what to do,
and, of course, what not to do.
And it happens in every
single-- it's constant.
It's wallpaper.
You are bombarded
with opportunities
to see these people, and
to watch them, and to learn
by simply observing them.
So those are the two reasons
that I do this presentation.
So today we'll make
some connections
between what they
do and what you
can do to advance in your
careers and in your businesses.
And so here they are.
This was the second
debate, I think,
and some people are gone now.
So tomorrow night, you'll see
the three people in the center
for the Democratic Debate.
How many of you are going
to spend Saturday evening
watching the Democratic Debate?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Fair enough.
And you guys are lucky.
You don't have to
wait until 9:00.
I'm in the New York area.
I have to wait until
9:00 PM to watch that.
But you can watch it,
of course, any time,
because they'll
record it and you'll
be able to watch it on YouTube.
So the three in the
middle will be there.
And then, the
Republicans, a few of them
are now gone, or on
different stages,
and so, yeah,
things have changed,
and they're changing rapidly.
It's a moving target.
And it's something that I
have to constantly figure
out and work on,
because, again, there
have been so many debates
and so many changes
that it's been
difficult to keep up.
I couldn't even update
from the other day
because I was so busy.
But there was a debate on
Tuesday, I think it was.
So it doesn't matter
whether you want
to move to Pennsylvania
Avenue, you
want to move into 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue,
or you want to move
up in Silicon Valley.
The better communicator, or the
best communicator, will win.
I want to make it very clear--
you do not have to be perfect.
You do not have to be great.
You just have to be better
than the competition.
It's like the Olympics.
You just have to win by
a fraction of a point.
And that is the way it
is for these candidates,
and for you, as well.
So there are five components
to candidate communications
success.
Let's list five components.
The first is presentation
skills and public speaking.
This is the biggest one.
It's the most important one.
It's the way that we get to
know them a little better,
or they try to get us to
know them a little better.
And we'll spend most of the
time on the presentation skills
and public speaking today.
The second one is content.
Message.
So we're going to spend
some time on their slogans,
and what they use
for their slogans.
But generally, it's
their messaging.
What exactly are they saying?
And then, beyond the
message itself, discipline.
How often do they
repeat the message?
Do they stick with
the same message?
Are they testing some new
versions and variations
of the message?
And how do they put those--
the sloganeering is great,
I find it fascinating,
because if you put together
slogans in a certain way, they
should roll off your tongue
and they should
be very memorable,
and they should have some
kind of an emotional impact.
The third issue is the
personal narrative.
This is the story
of who they are,
how they come to be who they
are, and how they're formed.
And this is another
way that we end up
feeling like he or she
gets me, or he or she
doesn't get me at all.
And then there are two final
communication components
that we're not going to have
time to talk about here today.
And the fourth one is
interpersonal communication,
one-on-one communication,
or one-on-small-groups,
that's very important
in business,
hugely important in business,
but we don't have time to go
into that in any detail today.
One of the things
that you should know
is that, as the
race narrows down,
and the press pool
isn't so spread out,
spread so thin, that they
will be following the two
eventual nominees.
And what will happen
is, these nominees
will be photographed in the
diners, in the boutiques,
in the shops, in the businesses,
the manufacturing businesses.
Maybe they'll come to Google,
but only to get money.
Right?
Because they only come to
New York and Connecticut
to get money.
We never see them, either.
But so they come,
they'll be photographed,
and reporters will report on
how they interact, one-on-one,
with the "regular folks," OK?
That's what they
think of, and that's
how they qualify it--
the regular folks.
And then the final communication
component is the spouse.
Not going to talk about
that at all today.
[LAUGHTER] Very hard to talk
about for obvious reasons.
But we do have some interesting
spousal possibilities
for the potential First
Spouse this time, right?
So let's start with the public
speaking and presentation.
And I want to play
a video or two.
This was Barack Obama at the
2004 Democratic Convention.
How many of you have seen this?
All right.
This is just a clip.
Look at how young he looks.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
-It is that fundamental belief.
It is that fundamental belief--
I am my brother's keeper,
I am my sister's keeper--
that makes this country work.
It's what allows us to
pursue our individual dreams,
and yet still come together
as one American family.
E pluribus unum.
Out of many, one.
Now, even as we
speak, there are those
who are preparing to divide us.
The spin masters, the
negative-ad peddlers,
who embrace the politics
of anything goes.
Well, I say to
them tonight, there
is not a liberal America
and a conservative America.
There is the United
States of America.
[CHEERING]
There is not a black
America and a white America,
a Latino America,
an Asian America.
There's the United
States of America.
[CHEERING]
The pundits-- the pundits like
to slice and dice our country
into red states and blue states.
Red states for Republicans,
blue states for Democrats.
But I've got news for them, too.
We worship an awesome
god in the blue states,
and we don't like Federal agents
poking around in our libraries
in the red states.
[CHEERING]
We coach little league
in the blue states,
and yes, we've got some Gay
friends in the red states.
[CHEERING]
There are patriots who
opposed the war in Iraq,
and there are patriots who
supported the war in Iraq.
[END PLAYBACK]
RUTH SHERMAN: OK.
So again, look at what
happens to you when you spend
eight years as the President.
You get grey, and you get lined.
[LAUGHS] All right.
I remember where I was
when this happened.
How many of you
remember where you were?
Right.
OK.
So a memorable talk, you
will remember where you were
and what you were doing.
I was in my bedroom.
I was picking up.
I was watching the
Democratic Convention.
It's such a boring
thing to watch.
Because they get up, most of
them are terrible speakers,
and they speak, and it
goes on and on and on.
Right?
And then I remember hearing him.
I didn't know who he was.
I'd never heard of him before.
And I remember hearing his
voice, and doing a double-take.
Sitting down on the end of my
bed and listening to his talk,
and thinking, he's
going to be somebody.
Little did I know.
Four years later,
he's president.
All right.
Let's take a look
at another video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Rudy Giuliani said he thought
that there may be some Reagan
qualities to Donald Trump.
So Carly Fiorina, is he
getting the better of you?
-I don't know.
I didn't get a phone
call from Bill Clinton
before I jumped in the race.
Did any of you get a phone
call from Bill Clinton?
I didn't.
Maybe it's because I hadn't
given money the foundation,
or donated to his
wife's Senate campaign.
Here's the thing that
I would ask Donald
Trump, in all seriousness.
He is the Party's front-runner
right now, and good for him.
I think he's tapped into
an anger that people feel.
They're sick of
politics as usual.
You know, whatever
your issue, your cause,
the festering problem you
hoped would be resolved,
the political class
has failed you.
That's just a fact.
And that's what Donald
Trump taps into.
I would also just say this.
Since he has changed his mind
on amnesty, on health care,
and on abortion,
I would just ask,
what are the principles
by which he will govern?
-In an interview last week
in "Rolling Stone Magazine,"
Donald Trump said the
following about you.
Quote, "Look at that face.
Would anyone vote for that?
Can you imagine that the
face of our next President?"
-You know, it's
interesting to me.
Mr. Trump said this he
heard Mr. Bush very clearly,
and what Mr Bush said.
I think women all over this
country heard very clearly what
Mr. Trump said.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
-I think she's got
a beautiful face,
and I think she's
a beautiful woman.
-All right, on that note.
[END PLAYBACK]
RUTH SHERMAN: And it's if
looks could kill, right?
Talk about nonverbal
communication.
All right.
So one of the
things that I think
is super important to know
is that these two people
were nobodies before
they communicated
to us in a very skilled way.
Not Trump.
He was not a nobody.
But people didn't know
who Carly Fiorina was.
You knew who she was.
I know who she is, because
I follow business news.
But in the rest of the
country, she was an unknown.
She's the only one who made
it from the quote unquote
"undercard debate"
to the main stage.
And she's remained there.
Even though, in between
her debate performances,
supposedly, what I understand
is her poll numbers decline.
But her performances
continue to be pretty good.
She's a gifted communicator.
But she works at it.
Same thing for Barack Obama.
Nobody knew who he was.
He had been a community
organizer in Chicago.
He had been a State
Senator, State Legislator,
and then he got elected
to the US Senate.
And he was there for
less than three years
when he started running.
I think it was about
two years when he
started to run for President.
So he was a nobody.
And this was the most
fascinating thing to me,
because here were two
people nobody's ever
heard about before.
Suddenly they're players.
It opens the door for people.
And if it opens
the door for them,
it can open the door for you.
So what are presentation skills
and public speaking skills?
They are all nonverbal.
How you look, how you
sound, how you move.
And, if you're on a
stage, how you travel.
And when we talk about
traveling on stage,
it's not standing behind
a lectern, necessarily.
It's about how you command
the room, or the stage,
or the platform--
whatever you're on.
And then voice is
part of how you sound,
and it's in a
category by itself.
So let's talk a little bit about
each of the nonverbal codes.
And we call them codes
because they are exactly that.
They are simply not using words.
How we communicate
without using words.
So one of the big things
that we've heard about
is Bernie Sanders
and his hand gesture.
Bernie Sanders has this
hand gesture that he uses.
When he talks, he punctuate
each syllable of each word.
And uses his right hand, and
sometimes he gets his left hand
into the act.
But he punctuates each
syllable of each word.
And the problem that
he's had with that
is that when you
are speaking, you're
speaking in a faster
manner, your syllables
are moving more quickly
off your tongue,
than your hand can move.
So you're late with your hands.
OK?
And we'll see that
in just a second.
Just slightly late, and I'm
exaggerating, but you're late.
And it's a bit of a
distraction because of that.
So we're going to take a
look at that in a minute.
But let's talk a little
bit about gestures
and why they're so important.
The research shows that
gestures help us think.
They help us think.
I don't know about
any of you, but when
you get to a certain
age, like I am,
you're looking for
words sometimes.
Trying to find words.
Sometimes I'm struggling,
trying to find a word,
and I'm waving my
hand around up here
as if I can pluck it out of the
air and put it into my brain.
And many of us do that.
We use our hands.
And as we express
ourselves, we use our hands.
And if you watch
what people do, even
in interpersonal communication,
you are using their hands.
If there's a culture
that does not
use its hands to
accompany the spoken word,
it hasn't been discovered yet.
Hasn't been discovered yet.
And one of the ways they
know that hand gestures are
so important is that blind
people gesture, and deaf people
gesture in addition to signing.
So gestures are
hugely important.
So not only do
they help us think,
but they help
everyone else learn.
Nonverbal communication,
the way you look,
sound, move, and travel,
gives meaning to your words.
It makes you believable.
Give you a quick example.
If I stood here like this,
and I said, I'm Ruth Sherman,
and I'm a communications expert,
and if you stay here and listen
to me for an hour, you are
going to learn so much about how
to be a great speaker.
So what I'm doing
is, I'm contradicting
what I'm saying with my body
language and my movements.
Now, you know, people complain
to me when I give that example.
And, well, Ruth, you're
a professional speaker.
You have to be good at this.
You have to model the behavior.
And there's an element
of truth to that.
But the fact is that anybody
who gets up and talks
about something that
they're passionate about
has to be able to
display that passion.
Because there's so
much competition
that people will go to the next
person who's able to interest
and engage that audience.
So display your passion.
In fact, people
often come to me--
How many of you feel
if you move too much,
or you become too
theatrical, you
think of it as too
theatrical, too slick,
that it will be inauthentic?
Raise your hands if
you think that it will
be inauthentic and not real.
Yeah.
And people often ask me,
you know, that's not me,
it would be phony, it
would not be authentic.
And my response to that
is that authenticity
is often misunderstood,
and sometimes overrated.
And I'll explain
that in a minute.
And the second thing is,
I don't care how you feel.
I only care-- my clients,
I only care how
you look and sound,
because here's what
I know for sure.
I'm certain about it.
That if the way
you look and sound
is engaging with your
audience, if your audience
is engaged with you, that
that feedback will make you
feel confident.
So it's a feedback loop
that adds to the confidence.
The way you look,
sound, move, and travel.
Let's take a quick look
at Bernie Sanders' hands.
Let's see.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And what Democratic
Socialism is about,
is saying that it
is immoral and wrong
that the top 1/10 of 1% in
this country own almost 90%,
own almost as much as
wealth as the bottom 90%.
That it is wrong today,
in a rigged economy,
the 57% of all new income
is going to the top 1%.
That when you look
around the world,
you see ever other major
country providing health care
to all people as a right,
except the United States.
You see every other major
country saying to moms
that when you have
a baby, we're not
going to separate you
from your newborn baby,
because we are going
to have, we are
going to have medical
and family paid
leave like every other
country on earth.
Those are some of the
principles that I believe in.
And I think we should look
to countries like Denmark,
like Sweden, and
Norway, and learn
from what they have accomplished
for their working people.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
RUTH SHERMAN: So
Sanders is a little bit
distracting with his hands.
And one of the things--
"Time Magazine"
called me right before
the Democratic debate
of a couple of weeks
ago, and they said, well,
what do they have to do?
And I had been
reading, probably,
possibly like you did,
that Bernie Sanders wasn't
practicing.
Wasn't rehearsing.
That was not authentic.
OK.
That wasn't going
to work for him.
And I said, if what
I'm reading is true,
I think it's going to hurt him.
And I think that
it did hurt him.
I don't think that he was
ready for the TV camera.
It's very different to
be in a debate situation
where you are speaking
primarily to the TV audience.
In the room are all people
who agree with you already.
They're all, or they're all
almost, agreeing with you.
They're all Democrats
in the room.
But the people who are
out there are people
that you have to persuade.
Because you cannot win with
only one party voting for you.
You have to have some
votes from the other party,
and certainly from independents.
The other thing that he does
is he leans on the podium.
Podiums are made for
six-foot-tall men, not for--
or six-foot-tall
people, I should say.
But, you know, he leans
on the podium like this,
and it is a distraction.
And it makes him look
older and more hunched
than he needs to be.
He's a fit man, and he
simply doesn't have to--
he has to appeal to a much
broader swath of the electorate
than he's able to, if
he does it this way.
The other thing that
he does, of course,
is he speaks in pretty
much a loud voice.
You know, his voice is loud.
It's one volume level.
Great for the big
arena speeches,
the kinds of speeches
that he's giving,
and that he's attracting a
lot of people to come to.
But one of the
things that happens
when you speak with
one volume level
is that, if everything's
important, nothing's important.
So what I noticed--
it was interesting,
because Carly
Fiorina, I think, is
a gifted communicator, and a
very-- and she works at it.
And, you know, it's funny.
I cannot evaluate
her tenure at HP.
I cannot.
I'm not an MBA.
I don't know whether she
did a good job, whether she
didn't do a good job.
I read that she
All of that.
I read everything that they
put out there about her.
But I can absolutely see
how she could have persuaded
her board of very
smart people to do
certain things that were perhaps
not good for the company.
I can see it.
Now, that is not
what I advocate.
It don't advocate it.
I advocate, of course,
knowing your stuff
and doing good things.
And being able to communicate
those good things.
Because the way you speak
is the operational vehicle
for your message.
For your knowledge.
How do you get it
out there to people,
but for speaking
to people about it?
And, you know, for all of
the texting and emailing
and written language
that we use,
we still speak far more
than we do any of that.
Far more.
And we don't even
realize it, because we're
sitting at our computers,
typing away all the time.
But the fact is that
we do it far more,
and it's much more efficient.
So the speaking voice.
Talked about the speaking voice.
I mentioned it.
It's in a class by
itself because it
has several components.
Volume, which we just
talked about with Sanders.
It has a tone,
intonation, expression, so
the way we use pitch, highs
and lows, to express our voice
and all of the range in between.
By the way, every language
has its own music.
Has its own linguistic music.
So that's why, when we
speak a foreign language,
our native accent is there.
Because we're using our
music from our native tongue
to speak the other language,
the foreign language.
But the other things
that is has, of course,
is the accent and dialect, and
then, as I mentioned, volume,
tone, expression, et cetera.
And rate.
And pace.
So let's listen
to two candidates,
back to back-- Jeb Bush and
Martin O'Malley, both of whom,
I think, have beautiful
speaking voices.
Let's take a quick listen.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Question, just before
you move on from Sanders,
why isn't he-- you know, these
campaigns cost tens or hundreds
of millions of dollars, why, and
it's pretty clear to everybody,
why hasn't he
actually addressed it?
RUTH SHERMAN: Your guess
is as good as mine.
I don't have inside information.
Sadly.
AUDIENCE: Do you think he
knows that this hurting him?
RUTH SHERMAN: I'm sure
somebody's telling him.
I would guess
But either he's not
listening, or he doesn't care,
or he thinks that it will impact
his quote unquote authenticity.
And, you know.
So I don't know.
But that's the only
thing I can think of.
That's the only
Let's take a quick look, or
listen, to O'Malley and Bush.
And I'll try to push
the right button here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-To a certain extent.
I always knew this
was going to be hard.
I never felt like I
was a front-runner,
because we hadn't earned it.
We haven't-- Just starting
out on the journey,
you've got to go earn it.
I've got to get better
at debating, I guess,
or performing.
Whatever that's called.
And I will.
I'm a grinder.
I'm very competitive.
And so I feel good
about where we are.
-What is that?
You keep saying, I'm a grinder.
What does that mean?
-That means, I described
it as I eat nails
before I have breakfast.
I'm focused.
I'm competitive.
I've set high
expectations on myself.
I knew this was
going to be hard.
- --New leadership.
You're ready to challenge
her, aren't you?
-Well, I think that
our country always
benefits from new leadership
and new perspectives.
And let's be honest here.
The Presidency of
the United States
is not some crown to be
passed between two families.
It is an awesome
and sacred trust
to be earned and exercised on
behalf of the American people.
-Those two families,
Bush and Clinton?
-Well, right now, George,
you know, any two families.
But look.
In order for us to
make an economy again,
where people can work
hard and get ahead,
we need a president
who is on our side.
A president who's
willing to take
on powerful, wealthy,
special interests,
in order to restore that
sort of American economy
where, wherever you start
on the earning spectrum,
you can get ahead
through your hard work.
[END PLAYBACK]
RUTH SHERMAN: So if we
listen to O'Malley and Bush,
their voices are very pleasing.
I think it was interesting
when Bush said, "I'm a grinder.
I'm a grinder."
It's like, well,
what does that mean?
And you don't look like
a grinder right now.
So.
He could've-- when she asked
him what a grinder was,
we could have learned what
that was if he expressed it
a certain way.
But O'Malley and
Bush are pretty good.
Now the other thing
that happens--
I don't have the recordings
of the women's voices,
except you heard
Carly Fiorina before.
The women's voices, Hillary
Clinton and Carly Fiorina,
they're OK.
They're good enough voices.
They're not beautiful women's
voices, like-- oh, gosh.
One of the great women's voices
right now that you could listen
to would be Diane Sawyer.
Probably the best public voice
that you can hear from a woman.
Beautifully articulated and well
done, and very well-trained,
of course.
But their voices are good.
They're good enough.
And they've learned
how to create and use
their leadership voices.
One of the things that
you don't hear from them,
that we hear a lot, I
hear a lot among clients,
and you may hear it a lot,
but I want you to become
more aware of this, is uptalk.
Uptalk sounds like this.
Everything sounds
like a question.
All right?
And I'm being very
nasal right now,
and I'm trying to imitate it.
And I'm a girl, I'm a
woman, so this is the way
it sounds when women do it.
Men do it, too.
Women get nailed
for more, sadly.
But that is the way it is.
So let me play this for you.
You'll hear another habit,
which is called vocal fry.
Which I can't do
as well as she can.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-America's young
women are running out
of oxygen. What else could
explain why so many of them
sound like this.
-So cute.
So cute.
-Hi.
Hi.
-Just kind of like my, you
know, motto, you know, motto.
-Kim and Khloe
just don't get it.
Get it.
[END PLAYBACK]
RUTH SHERMAN:
[LAUGHS] So vocal fry.
Well, actually,
that's when you--
you know that the air is
just coming out so slowly.
You're not pushing the air over
your vocal cords fast enough.
That's what it is.
I remember when George W. Bush--
now, that's interesting, too.
That's an interesting
juxtaposition.
George W. Bush's
voice was awful.
Awful.
All right?
So you would think
brothers sound alike.
They don't.
You know, my sisters and I
sound alike, but, I don't know.
They lost that gene somewhere.
OK.
So.
Voice.
Very important.
Be assertive.
Use your voice.
You know, if your
voice is too high,
lower it a little
bit, for women.
Men, make sure you push that
air over your vocal cords,
so you don't get vocal fry.
All right?
What I was going to say a moment
ago was, when George W. Bush,
I remember, entertaining
the thought, early
in his Presidency, of
having Henry Kissinger do
some kind of work.
And I thought, oh my god, if
I have to listen-- You know,
I've been around a long time.
I remember when Kissinger
was on TV all the time.
And I thought, if I have to
listen to that every night
on the news, kill myself.
[LAUGHTER]
Kill myself.
Only because of his voice.
[LAUGHS] All right.
The other nonverbal
code of communication
we can talk about briefly
today is dress and adornment.
Dress and adornment.
Everything you
weren't born wearing.
All the choices that we make.
All the choices we
make, from the way
we comb our hair, haircuts,
everything, the whole thing.
Dress and adornment.
There's a uniform,
obviously, that politicians
have to wear if they're
on the debates stages,
or in a formal setting.
The men are going to
be wearing a dark suit,
a light-colored shirt,
and a red or blue-ish tie.
That's it.
All right?
The women have more choices,
and it's more fraught.
It's more fraught.
I remember somebody
asking me why
Hillary Clinton
wore that blue suit
on the first Democratic debate.
I said I didn't think she
wanted to stand out as much.
She didn't want to
be-- Women are always
going to be approached
or criticized, certainly,
but there's always going
to be comments about what
it is that they wear.
So I think she wanted
to lessen that.
And I think it worked for her.
So dress and adornment.
You know, I thought
a lot about what
I was going to wear to
here, because I'm not
going to wear this to a bank.
I'm not wearing this outfit
to J. P. Morgan when I go
and I talk to them.
I wore a suit yesterday
at Accenture in San Jose,
because I was speaking
to a group there.
It was different.
I knew, and I asked [? Doma, ?]
what's the dress code?
And she told me informal.
And I knew that.
I knew it was informal.
But I wanted to
confirm it, because I
hadn't been here before.
So I thought, OK, well, what
can I wear that's informal
but that's still me?
You know, still it's got
a little bit of an edge,
little bit stylish,
because I'm not
going to come in here
in jeans and a T-shirt,
or even khakis and
a button-down shirt.
That's not me.
So I was glad to be able to
find something that I had,
that I thought would work.
So I'll leave that up to you.
You can let me know whether
you think it works or not.
But--
AUDIENCE: It's working.
RUTH SHERMAN: It's working?
Thank you. [LAUGHS] Thank you.
I'm glad about that.
But the whole idea
that we think,
oh, we get up in the morning, in
Silicon Valley, that you think,
oh gosh, I don't have to
worry about any of that stuff,
because what you're
communicating,
of course, is this
is not important.
This isn't important.
This is important.
But guess what?
A long time ago, somebody
chose this uniform for you.
Somebody chose it.
And it, in fact,
communicates something.
You cannot get away from
communicating, regardless,
whether you think you are,
or you think you aren't.
One more thing about
presentation skills
and public speaking.
In order to get good at it,
you have got to practice.
You've got to practice, and
you have to say it out loud.
In your head does not count.
We're all very eloquent
in our own heads.
We are.
We imagine ourselves getting
up on a stage or platform,
or conducting that meeting,
and being wonderful.
It doesn't work that way.
If you practice, say
it out loud a lot,
and then you get
to the other side,
where you can get up
there, and maybe you're
nervous to begin with.
And by the way, I don't call
it stage fright anymore.
I just saw this.
Call it stage appreciation.
OK?
Think about it that way.
It's a re-frame of that feeling.
But the idea that
you might be nervous,
and you get up on a stage,
and you're worried about it,
if you've practiced,
I guarantee you
that once you start
speaking, it will dissipate.
And you'll be able to
be yourself and go off
the reservation, go off
your prepared remarks
and get back on again
much more easily.
So practice.
Practice plus experience
equal spontaneity.
Let's move on to message.
And then we're going to talk
about the personal narrative.
We're not going to spend as
much time on either of those
as we did on the presentation
skills and public speaking.
And then we'll leave
enough time for questions,
because I'd love to hear
what you have to say,
and what your questions are.
All right. #AllinForJeb.
This is Jeb Bush's current--
that was on his website a month
or so ago.
I understand that
he has a new logo,
and I didn't see it on his
website, called Jeb Can Fix It.
And I'm thinking, fix what?
Fix himself?
Fix his presentation?
Fix his failing campaign?
What is Jeb going to fix?
Jeb can fix it.
Interesting.
Yeah?
All right.
Let's see.
Who else?
Who knows Carly
Fiorina's-- this is a test.
Fiorina's slogan?
Anybody?
Right.
Pardon me?
[LAUGHTER]
What was that?
I didn't hear it.
What was it?
Tell me.
AUDIENCE: I said,
HP wasn't that bad.
RUTH SHERMAN: [LAUGHS] Probably.
All right.
So Carly Fiorina.
What about Ben Carson.
Anybody know Ben
Carson's slogan?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RUTH SHERMAN: Pardon?
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH SHERMAN: What was that?
AUDIENCE: I said, [INAUDIBLE].
RUTH SHERMAN: [LAUGHS]
What about, who else?
Marco Rubio.
Anybody know his slogan?
No, right?
Hillary Clinton?
Nope.
Bernie Sanders?
Do you know Donald Trump's?
What's Donald Trump's?
AUDIENCE: Make
America Great Again.
RUTH SHERMAN: Make
We're going to come back
to that in a minute.
There's a reason that you
know Donald Trump's and you
don't know the others.
There's a reason.
All right.
All In For Jeb.
Let's see what else
we've got here.
Not bad.
New Possibilities.
Real Leadership.
Not bad.
It's OK.
It says a bit about who she
is, and real leadership,
she's going back to
her leadership of HP.
This one scares me.
Honestly.
Heal.
Inspire.
Revive.
Yes, you've got to
revive yourself.
You know, you
better-- It's like,
the first two I don't mind.
The heal, inspire, I like those.
But then revive
is from the dead?
What?
You know?
All right.
Are You Ready For A
New American Century?
He had just A New
American Century.
I just picked this up a couple
of days ago, so he's added.
He's testing.
Or he's using it as a sentence,
a question, in this case.
Are you ready for?
I like A New American Century.
I think that it's good.
It's inspirational.
There's something
interesting about it,
and it rolls off the tongue.
Hillary doesn't have a
slogan, but she's got a logo.
When I first saw this,
I'm thinking, what?
What?
And, you know, it's
pointing to the right.
And then it grew on me.
I started to look at it,
and I thought, it's modern,
it's clean, a lot
can be done with it.
You can put the LGBT,
rainbow colors on it,
and you can also do
something like this.
[LAUGHTER]
You know people will do that.
That's the problem with logos.
Not only your fans
can do things with it,
but the opposition can
also do things with it.
And then, of course, we've
got Make America Great
Again, which you
many of you knew.
So let's just break that down.
What is a slogan?
A slogan is a
combination of words
that is framed in a way that
has an emotional impact.
Framing is a way of
inserting a point of view
into one word or a few words.
And we want to keep
an economy of words,
but it's not ultimately
necessary, always necessary,
for it to be a very few words.
My favorite one-word
frame right now
is Democrat as an adjective.
Democrat congress, Democrat
president, Democrat idea,
as opposed to "democratic."
That's a very interesting frame.
Make America Great Again.
This is what I call a
"God Damn It" statement.
It's a God Damn It statement.
So let's do an
analysis of the words.
Make-- it's a command.
Right?
Make.
We're going to make.
I'll make, you make, we make.
America-- self-explanatory,
the country, our great country.
Great-- great, everybody
thinks of America as great,
or we want to think
of America as great.
Not everybody does, but
we want to, we hope to,
we aspire to that.
And then, Again-- ah,
that's the key word.
That's the key word, "again."
America was great once.
It isn't any more.
And go with Donald Trump,
it'll be great again.
Stick with me, and
it will happen again.
So this is a frame.
It's a frame.
The other thing that
happens with this slogan
is the way the word
endings and beginnings are.
So "make America--" ck ah.
So the end of "make"
is a "ck" sound.
And then America
is a vowel, right?
It's a short "a."
So "make America" flows.
"Great." "Make America great."
Eh, that's a little bit
different, not as smooth.
But "great again."
So it flows.
It rolls off the
tongue really easily.
So this is what Trump does.
And he does it very, very well.
And the other thing that
he does, is he keeps it,
he repeats it all the time.
This is called
"message discipline."
It's on his hat.
He does it on his Insta.
Anybody connected
with his Instagram?
Do you follow him on Insta?
Oh, he's amazing.
Just amazing.
He blows me away as a
media-- he's media expert.
He's a genius at keeping
himself in the public eye,
on the front page, getting ink.
In fact, the journalists
I talk to complain
that because media is so
corporate at this point,
they keep Donald Trump in the
news because it sells papers,
and it sells advertising time.
This is a sad but true thing
about our media industry.
They should be protecting us.
I don't think they're
doing as good a job
as they should with this.
So "Make America Great
Again," a God Damn It
statement that rolls off
the tongue really easily.
As I was talking about earlier,
a great one-word frame now,
Democrat.
Some Republican message
mavens, Frank Luntz.
Anybody know who Frank Luntz is?
He's a wonderful, smart,
language-- he's a sociologist,
I believe, but he does
a lot of the polling.
He's a pollster for
the Republicans.
He has a book.
You should get this book.
It's called "Words That Work."
It's not what you say,
it's what people hear.
Not what you say,
It's all about framing
and using advertising,
and he's created a lot
of different frames.
So think about these
frames and politics.
Tax cuts, or tax relief?
Tax cuts?
Tax relief?
Tax cuts, eh, we hear
that all the time.
Tax relief implies that
there's oppression.
There's oppression, and there's
been a bad guy, a villain,
and then somebody
rides to the rescue,
and lifts the pressure off of
you, and your taxes go down,
and everybody's
happily ever after.
All right.
Another one-- drilling for
oil, or energy exploration?
Which can you get behind?
They're the same thing.
Here's another one.
Estate tax, or death tax?
[GASPING] Right?
Not only do I have to
pay taxes when I'm alive.
When I die, they
take more taxes.
It's like, ugh!
Right?
Estates?
That's from Greenwich.
That's where I live, in
Greenwich, Connecticut.
You know, that's where the
estates-- and around here.
That's really the estates are.
As I mentioned,
Democrat as a one-word
frame that you
hear more and more.
A new frame that
I've heard, as they
talk about the Affordable
Care Act, Obamacare,
they talk about
entanglement in Obamacare.
Entanglement is
never a good thing.
That's what our banks do to us.
They entangle us, right?
We've got our credit card
with them, our checking,
our savings, our
investments, whatever it is.
And what ends up happening is,
if you want to change banks,
you kind of go through
a lot of stuff to do it.
It's called being entangled.
They're talking about the
ACA now as entanglement.
Very interesting.
Business frames.
Why do I want a grande when
a medium is the same thing,
and cheaper?
Why do I want that?
Because it's a grande.
And it get served by a barrista,
versus a coffee server,
or a counter person.
A counter person serves tepid
coffee in a chipped porcelain
cup.
A barrista serves
delicious, fair-trade coffee
in a cool Christmas cup, to
stay with the time, right?
Stick with the times.
A red cup, a Christmasy
cup, a holiday cup.
And there's Wi-Fi.
It's a frame.
The other thing.
Let's see.
There was one more that I
wanted to make sure-- Oh!
Gambling, or gaming?
Gambling?
Sinful.
Gaming?
Fun.
Right?
So it's very fascinating
what people do about this.
And so you can use it, too.
You can absolutely
use frames as you're
presenting your ideas in your
meetings to your higher-ups,
to your colleagues.
Think about what's
in it for them.
What is it about the frame?
What is the aspirational
piece of that?
Because that's what
a good frame does.
It makes you feel good.
It makes you feel better.
It makes you think that your
life is going to be better,
or your work, or
your business, is
going to be easier, if you do
what it is that you're saying,
if you framed it the right way.
So start thinking about that.
And start thinking about,
also, the message discipline.
Repeating it over and
over and over again.
We want it to be aspirational,
and you want to repeat it.
By the way, test it,
and you'll see this.
Just like we saw with Marco
Rubio's-- I think it was this
last one.
Nope, that was
"I'm with stupid."
Sorry.
Here we go.
You know, with Rubio, he's
testing this new piece of it.
He's putting it into a question.
But before, it was just
"A New American Century."
He's testing it.
We'll see.
So they test things,
just like we do,
just like you do, in
business to see what works.
All right.
Let's go to the
personal narrative.
AUDIENCE: One other
thing. [INAUDIBLE]
slogan [INAUDIBLE] you see that
first each time to advertise
[INAUDIBLE] who think that
America's not great any more,
and then, once he does
that, [INAUDIBLE].
And these two parts
combine [INAUDIBLE]
message that I've seen here.
RUTH SHERMAN: Absolutely.
It's a simple frame, but I
think, you know, it's not new.
It's not a new
combination of words.
In fact, it was used around
the Reagan Administration.
They framed it, or when Ronald
Reagan was running for office.
There are only so many
words, simple words,
and simple declarative
statements, that exists,
that will work in
these contexts.
But I think it's his discipline.
He found an excellent
combination of words.
This was not an accident.
It was a good frame.
And he repeats it ad infinitum.
He repeats it constantly.
Let's see what I got here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Would you like to see him run?
-No.
I really don't.
I think it's a great country.
There are a lot
of great families.
They're just, there are
other people out there
that are very qualified,
and we've had enough Bushes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Having trouble
sleeping at night?
Too much energy?
Need some low energy?
-They have an HSA
in some companies.
Some companies don't.
But I think the
norm ought to be--
-Jeb.
For all your sleeping needs.
-So yesterday I announced
I'm running for President.
We're going to make
America great again.
I'm going up to New
Hampshire in a little while.
Lots of fun.
Make America great again.
The Academy Awards last night
were absolutely terrible.
Boring, ugly sets, everything.
I have the perfect
host for next year.
Me.
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH SHERMAN: You know?
I mean, he's interesting.
He's an interesting guy.
OK.
Let's talk about the
personal narrative.
The story.
The core.
The hero journey that each
person in the world takes.
Some people have a better
hero-journey story than others.
Like Barack Obama had a
fantastic hero-journey story.
But what happens if you've
been raised either wealthy,
or middle class, you don't
have that much hardship,
you haven't had to overcome
the same kinds of things
that somebody like
Obama had to overcome.
Or like Ben Carson now,
who's talking about what
he's had to overcome.
So what do you do about that?
Well, it's another way
that we get to know people.
One of the things that
I think is interesting,
as we look at
Hillary Clinton, she
was raised in a
middle-class family.
Her father was a businessman.
Her mother, she talks
about her mother
having been thrown
out of the house,
or having to leave
home at the age of 14
and make it on her own.
So she's talking about
that, but that hasn't quite
connected with people yet.
It hasn't quite connected.
I don't know that it will.
I think that there's
certain times when you just
have to run on your resume.
And I think that's what she
will end up doing, in terms
of telling her story,
in how she came up,
and how she came up through
the women's movement,
and became a professional
lawyer, and a partner
in a firm, and all of her work
for girls and women, et cetera.
And her resume is very
lengthy and quite impressive.
Carly Fiorina, from
secretary to CEO.
A little alliteration there.
And we can make fun
of her, and think,
like, she also was raised
in the middle class
or upper middle class family.
I don't think she had
much hardship growing up.
But the idea that
she was a secretary.
You know, she and I
are about the same age.
She-- When I started
working, I was a receptionist
in an accounting
firm in New York.
I couldn't get a job.
I wasn't an accountant.
But I wouldn't have been
able to get a job like you,
like all of the women now,
who graduate college and get
real jobs, real
professional jobs.
It's an amazing transformation.
I sometimes think the
women's movement is stalled,
but then I come to places
like this, in Google,
and Accenture yesterday,
and I think, thank
god, it hasn't stalled.
It is much better.
It feels glacial.
But that's going to be
Carly Fiorina's frame.
Donald Trump has a frame story.
Donald Trump has a problem
talking about his life.
He came from a wealthy family.
His father was a developer.
He's mentioned one
thing about his--
had a brother who died
unexpectedly, or too young,
I think from alcoholism.
I think that was it.
But he doesn't
talk about it much,
so we don't really
know much about him.
But we don't really care,
because Donald Trump isn't
expected to be introspective.
So it's consistent.
It's interesting.
It's consistent with his brand.
Bernie Sanders has the story
of he's been in politics now
for 25 or 30 years,
I think about, yeah,
about 25 or 30 years,
so he can't go back
and say, well I'm
sort of an outsider.
He's not.
But what is it?
He comes from a small state.
What is it that Bernie Sanders
can bring to the table?
He's a father, I think,
of four children,
a grandfather of seven.
He talks about that
a lot, so that people
can relate to him in that way.
Ben Carson, we know his
story, and now they're
starting to pick
on him about it.
I don't know whether any of its
true, whether it's not true.
I don't have any idea.
But it's compelling stuff,
if you think about it.
One of the most
interesting things,
as I was following
politics in the-- I
remember when George Bush was
running against John Kerry.
Now George Bush is from
one of the first families
of American politics.
The Bush family.
Been in politics.
Wealthy New Englanders.
And then in Texas, oil
business, for decades.
So George Bush was running
against John Kerry.
John Kerry got the reputation
as being the patrician.
George Bush, his story
was, his narrative
was that he would be
filmed on his ranch,
clearing brush in his
flannel shirt and his jeans,
and his cowboy boots
and his cowboy hat,
and his dogs in tow, and in
his dusty pickup truck, right?
Clearing brush.
That's what he was always
doing on his weekends.
John Kerry was
windsurfing off Nantucket.
You don't do that if you
want to run for President,
and you want people to think
that you're not the patrician
one.
So their personal narrative
is going to be very important.
They're going to flesh this out.
It's going to come up,
and we're going to see it.
For you, in business, you
don't want to get too personal.
Not in a large group.
Certainly not.
With your colleagues, close
colleagues, and people
you have good
relationships with, yes.
You can tell them some
of your struggles.
But in business,
leaders that I work with
are always advised
to find something
that they can talk about
where it didn't work out
so well for them.
Where they failed, and how they
struggled with that failure,
and how they fixed
it and came back.
Whether it was they
were fired, or they
failed on a big project, or
something of that nature,
that makes them seem more human.
People will connect
with you if they
think, like I said at the
outset, when I was introducing
this, if they think that you
are a human being who can relate
to them, who gets
them, who knows
what the cost of an evening
out for dinner would be.
Who knows what the cost of a
roll of toilet paper would be.
So I want to close
by telling you
that it doesn't matter whether
you think you are good at this,
or you think you're not.
These are skills
that can be learned.
This is not inborn.
These are concrete skills
that can be learned.
I would imagine that Google
has all kinds of workshops.
If you need to go
a little further,
there's the National
Speakers Association.
And they have a San
Francisco chapter.
If you need to go further,
but closer to home,
look for your
Toastmasters chapter,
or somebody start
one here at Google,
if you don't already have one.
You have one.
Yeah.
You have probably
several, right?
Several chapters?
Yeah?
OK.
Not a surprise.
Go!
Do this stuff.
Get better at this.
Get some objective feedback.
Because it will
advance your career.
Because here's the
truth-- no matter
how much experience you
have, how long you've
been in business, how
much you love what you do,
and critically,
how smart you are,
if you don't have a
commanding presence, if you
don't know how to communicate,
you will continue to struggle.
You'll continue to be
underpaid and under-recognized.
And you'll continue
to labor to get
the people to find you, and help
you, and promote you, and give
you the bonuses and the
recognition you deserve.
These are the skills that cure
all those ills more quickly
than anything else.
A colleague of mine calls
it a shortcut to sales.
There are no shortcuts in life,
except communication and public
speaking.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
What questions do you have?
AUDIENCE: So I remember Barack
Obama being very articulate,
having a sense of he was
really speaking to me,
or he really has a message.
And since he's
been President, it
seems to me he's gotten worse.
Do you think that's true?
RUTH SHERMAN: Yes.
He has.
And I think that Obama was
a great reader of scripts.
He's a great reader of
scripts on the teleprompter.
He's not great off the cuff.
I mean, he knows how to
memorize a stump speech,
and he knows how to get out
there and engage an audience.
But what ends up happening, and
this happens with all of them,
by the way.
It's not just Obama.
We expected more
of him, I think,
because he was so
wonderful as a speaker.
Was so, like, whoa,
we'd been wandering
in this desert of bad
communicators for too long.
I had been.
I don't know about you.
I certainly had been.
And then they do it
over and over again.
It gets boring.
It gets boring because
they don't do anything new.
So--
AUDIENCE: I think
a lot of us here,
we don't give as many
presentations as you do,
of course, or any of
these politicians.
And then, at least,
what happens to me,
and probably many of us here,
is that we, all of a sudden,
are called upon by our manager--
hey, I want you to give a talk.
Like this happened a
few weeks ago to me.
All my managers said, would you
give a talk to these 200 people
at this-- And like, oh, man.
OK.
How do you-- I'm out of
practice, so to speak.
And like you said,
you need to practice.
But then, we don't have
that many opportunities.
So how do you get
practice without--
so that you're ready for when
the moment comes, without --
kind of like being a backup
quarterback, you know.
RUTH SHERMAN: Totally get it.
You get rusty, is
what you're saying.
You get rusty.
I get rusty, too.
My practice for this
started six weeks ago.
I've done this presentation.
I'm a professional speaker.
I speak all the time.
But I started six weeks ago.
I had notice, of course, and
started putting it together.
Every four years it changes.
And then, the last
couple of weeks, I
said it out loud every day.
Every day.
Because when you
say it out loud,
just-- And I know you don't
get that same kind of notice.
I'd like to know how
much time you did have.
AUDIENCE: Two weeks.
RUTH SHERMAN: You had two weeks?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RUTH SHERMAN: OK.
It's not ideal.
But it's something.
How long was the presentation?
AUDIENCE: 15 minutes.
RUTH SHERMAN: OK.
So think of it-- So let me just
give you the words per minute
calculation.
We speak at about
140 words per minute.
And a 15-minute talk, then,
just do the math on that.
So like, 2,000 words,
or 1,500 words,
something of that nature.
And you're not going
to write it all out.
But as you say it, you've
got to practice it.
And you can use a speaker clock,
like I have, to time yourself.
And you can use notes.
I'm using notes
today, everybody.
I'm looking at my
speaker's notes on here.
There's no law against that.
Are you allowed to
use notes, or slides?
OK, good.
So, yeah.
Just use your notes.
But practice enough.
I mean, if you've got
a week to do this,
then you're going to have
to get to work quickly.
AUDIENCE: Practice by
yourself, you mean?
RUTH SHERMAN: Yup.
AUDIENCE: With a video camera?
RUTH SHERMAN: You could
use a video camera,
but if it's going to be too
much of a pain in the neck--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RUTH SHERMAN:
Yeah, well even so.
Yeah.
If it's going to be too much
of a pain in the neck to set it
up and get that going.
And if you're not going to
watch it, then don't bother.
And that's the biggest thing.
It's very painful to
watch yourself on video.
It's like 100 times more
painful than listening to your
voicemail. [LAUGHS] Right?
It's terrible.
And even my celebrity
clients are like,
oh, god, don't show me-- It's
like, you gotta watch yourself.
But if it's going to stop you
from practicing, don't bother.
Don't bother.
It's ideal if you
could do it that way,
but only if you're
going to watch it.
But saying it out
loud is the key.
What you'll also find, and this
is something I didn't mention.
When you say it out loud
enough, the speech centers
in your brain are activated.
And things that you didn't
even consider to say,
like all kinds of
pithy things, come
to mind that you
wouldn't have considered.
So keep that in mind.
So saying it out
loud, and you probably
have to say it out loud every
day, probably several times
a day.
Another tip is to not always
start at the beginning.
Because then, of course,
you get interrupted,
and you put it down,
and then what happens?
You come back, and you start
again at the beginning.
And the beginning's great.
And the middle and the end suck.
They do.
It's what happens.
You have to start in the
middle sometimes, and take it
to the end, or go over some
chunks that are troublesome.
See how the words
roll off your tongue.
AUDIENCE: One thing I've been
practicing-- [INAUDIBLE].
I think one thing that I've
been practicing, after watching
myself do this presentation,
which was, let's say,
less than optimal, I realized
I speak really quickly.
And then, now I'm
trying to actually do
that in everyday life.
And so, how do you apply your
techniques from presentations
that you give to hundreds
or thousands of people,
to kind of groups of
one to three or four?
RUTH SHERMAN: Well,
I will tell you
that I also have the problem
of speaking too fast,
and it's a constant tape that's
playing in the back of my head
to modulate my rate.
So I used to, on my notes, put
a big "slow down," slow down,
on every page.
And then it became wallpaper,
and I had to change the color,
or change the-- right?
You blank it out after a while.
So I give myself some
kind of a tip, or helper,
or some kind of a
cue, that enables
me to pay attention to that.
And then, after
you do it enough,
and you see how slowing down
enables you to think better.
It enables you to think better,
and come up, and then entertain
questions, and not
get, perhaps, flustered
if you make a mistake, or
you're reading the room,
and things aren't
going that well.
Or you think they're not.
You imagine they're
not going well.
I mean, just because people
aren't looking at you doesn't
mean they're not going well.
But those are some of
the things that I do,
and that I've tried to do.
And then, the more you do
it, the better you get.
Which is another reason, I
think, to do it more regularly,
and join a-- do
more Toastmasters.
Have more opportunities,
and volunteer more
for opportunities.
If you're not, it's a pain.
It's hard work.
It's hard to get good at this.
So that's another,
it's an addition.
But then it's like
riding a bike.
You get it, and you've
got it, and then
you only have to, like we said
earlier, just, when you get
rusty, and you just refresh.
You refresh.
AUDIENCE: I noticed,
started paying attention
to your hand gestures
after you called them out.
And no doubt you
must practice them.
No.
RUTH SHERMAN: I'm
just very animated
AUDIENCE: That's surprising.
RUTH SHERMAN: I'm
just very animated.
Yeah.
And not everybody has to
be as animated as I am.
AUDIENCE: So that they-- do
they come naturally to you?
Or is there a set of
particular hand gestures
that work better than others?
Or ones that you recommend
for people that it does not
come naturally to?
RUTH SHERMAN: OK.
So, I think maybe that answer
I gave you was too flip.
That, no, I don't practice.
Of course, over the
years I've worked on it.
All of this is technique.
It's technique.
It's as if you're learning a
golf swing, or a tennis swing,
or you're learning to
play a musical instrument.
You're learning technique.
And that's what this is.
So one of the techniques that
I learned, in terms of hands,
is keeping them
below-- you know,
not waving them around
in front of my face.
Not having them
up here too much.
If I'm on a stage,
like I am now.
A stage, an ish,
a platform, where
I have more physical
space and latitude,
I can be more expansive.
If I'm on a video, I
have to keep it smaller.
It's one of the problems
that Bernie Sanders, I think,
had when he was at
the Democratic debate.
I'll be very interested to
see what he does tomorrow.
I'll be very interested
to see if he pulls it
in a little bit for TV.
Which is different.
It's a box.
But keeping them lower, using
them to enhance my words,
to give meaning to my
words, because they do that.
And then also not
doing things like this,
or putting them in pockets.
Pockets are dangerous.
They really are.
They're dangerous.
Or putting them behind my back.
Or like this.
They call this fig leaf.
Fig leaf.
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH SHERMAN: All right?
Next time you watch a
politician at the podium,
watch all the aids
standing there like this.
Fig leaf.
So these are, yeah, so those
are some things not to do.
And just watch how
you move your hands
in your one-on-one
conversations,
your informal Google
as you're moving through
your daily life here.
And elsewhere.
I guarantee you, you use them.
You just have to bring
that to the stage.
AUDIENCE: Are you are
techniques universal,
or are they just for
the American culture?
Would this work in Brazil?
RUTH SHERMAN: Great question!
Yes.
This is American
business speech culture
that we're talking about today.
For sure.
It is different in other
cultures, as many of you
already know.
OK?
So what is your native country?
AUDIENCE: India.
RUTH SHERMAN: OK.
So it's going to be
different in India.
It's going to be
It's going to be different
even in other English-speaking
countries.
Different in the UK.
Different in Canada.
Although Canadian speakers
are very, very similar
to US business speakers.
But yes.
So I guess what
I would say here,
if you are speaking in the US,
you have to-- when in Rome,
as they say, do
what the Romans do.
And if you go back
and speak in India,
or elsewhere, make sure
you do your homework,
and see what it is they're
going to find appealing,
and what it is they're
going to find off-putting.
That's what I have to do.
And I get in trouble.
I get in trouble.
AUDIENCE: What do you suggest we
should do if, when you can see
you're losing your audience?
RUTH SHERMAN: Oh, god.
That's an awful feeling.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do you have
any tips or suggestions
on how you can bring them back?
RUTH SHERMAN: OK, my
first tip-- [LAUGHS] Yeah.
One of the things that
you have to do beforehand,
you can prevent
losing your audience.
You can.
By making sure that your
content has what we call rhythm.
Rhythm is the interspersing of
stories, quotes, statistics,
funny things that happen to
you, or have happened to you.
And they happen to
us on a daily basis.
Or an interesting
article that you read.
Any kind of public
information that you
can bring in to
your presentation,
and interspersing it
throughout the presentation.
Because if the presentation is
all theory, all theoretical,
or all data, all technical,
you will lose your audience.
You will.
I don't care where you're
working, or what you're doing.
As human beings, this
is how we connect.
And there are ways to make
your information come alive,
and in how people enjoy it.
What I did today was, I
don't have it in color.
I don't have my notes in color.
I color-code my outline.
My outline is my points,
the theory, the data,
the boring stuff.
OK?
All the stuff that turns me on
and turns everybody else off
is in yellow.
Highlighted in yellow.
The stories are in pink.
And the applications, show of
hands, audience participation.
Maybe I'll put a video up there,
or I'll tell a funny story
and get people to laugh.
Where people are physically
engaged in some way,
that's in green.
If I see everything, there's too
much yellow, I gotta change it,
because I know I'm going
to lose the audience.
So that's what you do.
You want to prevent
it to begin with.
The second thing
that you want to do
is, if you do see
people falling asleep,
doing other things, not engaged,
their body language, whatever
is going wrong, or you
think it's going wrong,
maybe it's not your fault.
Maybe they had a bad night.
Maybe the baby kept them up
all night, or they're sick,
or they've just had a bad
phone call before they
came into your meeting, and, you
know, something's going badly.
So it's not always your
fault. I kind of try
to go there, when I feel
like I'm losing an audience.
But I think you can prevent
it, for the most part.
And that was a
huge lesson for me.
Because just like everybody
else, all that theory,
all that theoretical
stuff, you know,
how to breathe to give
a good speaking voice.
It's like, no.
No, don't.
I hired a coach to help me.
No, you can't say that.
It's boring.
OK.
So it's a big lesson.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RUTH SHERMAN: You're welcome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
Thanks for coming.
I hope you all have
a good weekend.